they don't come much bigger than this
India v Pakistan a titanic clash that
almost didn't happen
Manchester's Old Trafford stadium is set
to become the latest battleground for
these two arch rivals its these stands
which will be packed with fanatical
supporters and hundreds of millions of
Indians and Pakistanis from right around
the world will be following every single
ball in what is branded as one of the
greatest rivalries in world sports half
a million fans applied for 26,000
tickets and they sold out in just 48
hours these Pakistan fans told me
they've got to score to settle
why he's always been there the tensions
always been there over the past you know
a few decades but this is tricky and you
know we're here to win hits player
country it's the biggest rivalry in
cricket the biggest rivalry around this
game it's going to be another
unpredictable one but hopefully you know
we're gonna
Indian fans from all over the world are
here and they told me this is the game
they've been waiting for
Starly got no chance not now old rapid
forget it it's all ours
you know just a game that you don't want
to lose it's a game that sometimes if
you win a trophy that that might be the
match that takes a bit of gloss always
be off with it's India vs. Pakistan
you're playing your neighbors so how do
the teams square up so in a heads a head
count Pakistan has got the edge over
India in victories of OD eyes winning 73
matches against India's just 54 yes but
India has won the World Cup twice
buckstein have won it just the once and
some people might argue even that was
lucky
okay well let's go back to 2017 the ICC
Champions Trophy final where the two
teams met here in the UK Pakistan a
crushing defeat of India by a hundred
and eighty run this house don't remind
me but you know as well as I do that
Pakistan have never beaten India in a
World Cup cricket match there are
legends of the game on both sides of the
border and was he Makram from Pakistan
told me the precious he faced in this
sporting clash freshly Jew relatives
your parents your cousins you go on the
road you go to the restaurant everybody
wants you to win against Indian why so
versa for Indian players you know a lot
of people a lot of you know media from
up out the world say it's a war but the
end of the day is a mom it's only a game
of cricket but this match was almost
called off when the two countries
teetered on the brink of war in February
India threatened to boycott the game at
the time the Indian team was heavily
criticized for wearing Indian army caps
on the field to show support for their
Armed Forces players from both sides
took to social media in a public display
of patriotism
sadly these tensions sometimes spill out
onto the streets of Britain this
violence between fans after the two
teams last faced each other here and
2017 but cricket like sport is a great
unifier
this match has the potential to leave
behind the enmity and politics of the
subcontinent instead they can come
together to celebrate one of the
greatest sporting fixtures in the world
in Dammam rashid with our shoosh joshi
Sky News